ciao ragazze allora io chiedo perdono
perché in questo video non caricato in
questo video
ciao a tutti allora io chiedo perdono
perché in questo video non ho caricato
manco ciao a tutti allora chiedo perdono
perché in questo mese ce l'ho fatta non
ho caricato video per il semplice fatto
che i miei fratelli siamo stati corti
non ho caricato manco mezzo video perché
non ho fatto non ho messo la nco non ho
fatto video non ho fatto ma come non ho
fatto non ho caricato video per il
semplice fatto che siamo stai disk non
ho caricato mezzo non ho fatto video
perché sono stato molto impegnato e
schiavizzato da mia madre a mettere a
posto la camera tipo in uno di quei
reality show o la mia stanza era della
mente te lo devo entrarvici distrutta
a maggior ragione adesso che grazie ha
vinto nella stanza
posso dire di essere felice o questo
magnifico stupendo elegante armadio
bianco e con uno scudetto quindi prende
che bossi che possono vedere se in
grasso e posso malusci super bowl
deprimermi continuare la battaglia
inoltre è dipinto il mio muro di rosso
per dare un senso di audacia e sexy
mamma sono una persona molto sensibile
io col mio onore tantissimi hanno
comprato questa spada che perfetta per
le mimetica sempre e quando mi sono
sentita e triste contenta è citata
rilassata in attivo in occasione di
niente
il presidente sono stato a pitturare
camera montare mobili della mattina alla
sera insomma sgobbare comunali noi non
ho mai trovato il tempo per potermi
metterli a girare anche perché insomma
sarebbe stata una specie di apocalypse
now questa stanza se avessi girarvi che
era carino ma no
insomma alla fine ha dovuto trovare un
compromesso ed è per questo che ho
deciso di fare un video tranquillo e
utile su come resistere a caldo e la
serie se non sapete cosa fare parlate
nel tempo ed io amo un sacco parlare del
tempo vai col meteo bentornati tutti
quanti a ripetizioni del m a che pesa
messa maglietta verde siccome mi ami il
green screen
sapevamo bene maricopa tassa cultura
d'epoca per gli odori fantasmi queste
storie comunque partiamo subito con le
previsioni
allora perché sono stivali el'italia
creatina l'italia è uno stivale ma non
segreto tra credo che siamo la patria
della moda ma stesso io adori ma chi
l'avrebbe mai detto comunque bando alle
ciance e parliamo subito di meteo oggi
giornata tranquilla bel sole tutti
quanto il mare domani purtroppo
specialmente nel nord italia
noi avremmo un problema perché piove ma
ha anzi no perché foto di piove perché
migliore a chi avrà sì
ok rimangio tutto quello che ho detto
forse è meglio non fare un video sul
caldo rimedi contro il caldo mangiare
leggero mangiare frutta bere tanta acqua
mangiare un ghiacciolo leccare il
freezer riempire la propria bellezza di
ghiaccio nebulizzare braccia viso parti
intime con acqua fresca sventolarsi con
un ventaglio mezzi garante un
ventilatore mettersi davanti al frigo
aperto creare dell'aria condizionata
artigianale come solo nel khyber
saprebbe fare scroccare l'aria
condizionata a casa di amici e chiudersi
in macchina e spararsi in faccia alla
revisionata andare in centro commerciale
per rubare di nascosto alla frescura
dell'aria condizionata a spogliarsi il
più possibile vestirsi con capi bianchi
che riflettano la luce vestirsi il più
possibile roba pesante importanti più
treni del deserto evitare colpi di
calore del sole il computer da dario le
lampade l'ipad l'iphone concedersi una
siesta pomeridiana mimetizzarsi
nell'ambiente non fare sesso cercare
sempre una zona d'ombra portarsi un
ombrello per creare zone d'ombra la
dolina ci siano sparsi sul pavimento di
marmo spalmati sul muro spalmarsi sugli
specchi di casa lamentarsi con qualche
amico della terribile ata cercare
immagini su internet che gli ultimi ad
evadere come immagini di vede o di
ragazze in bikini o di ragazze in bikini
sulla media pensare freddo vento e
freddo per è toccato fare una doccia
fredda
uno dice carlo in piedi in una bacinella
di acqua gelida immergere le feste
la congenita immergersi nel mare zheng
ricordarsi sempre non mi raccomando
sempre che c'è qualcuno che sta peggio
di noi
corre di macchina con le portiere aperte
far volare un aquilone vincere la
lotteria rifarsi il naso con svolgere
attività criminali come un po di minare
una nicchietta e soprattutto quella che
consiglio di più di ogni altra cosa
eseguire una passionale danza della
pioggia sperando per tempo cambio di
vento di freddo aero x cazzo e questi
non i consigli per sopravvivere al caldo
sono sicuro che appena chiudero questo
video rossi però perché ne saranno
venuti in mente non so quanti altri
vabbè infatti mi siete dimostri ciao